cultural and institutional innovations
conflict the war on terror being a
Republican I take the view of that
that's more important than global
warming what is the civilization that
you are talking about what do you think
of when you say Western civilization or
Islamic civilization history of our
country is an immigrant history former
governor of Massachusetts said we cannot
avoid any more of the illiterates that
they're sending to our shores you're
talking about the Irish American society
is like a treeless Prairie constantly
swept by a tornado many Muslim states
particularly in the Arab world or to
this day having a very difficult time
trying to define what exactly it even
means to be a Muslim state most people
live and think at the level of TV or if
they're really thoughtful they move it
up to magazines there's something
happens with human beings where they
there is a kind of dissatisfaction there
is a sort of a drive to make incremental
improvements it could be as simple as
modifying recipes it could be as big as
you know writing the US Constitution in
1925 the Los Angeles Chamber of Commerce
that an official reports that we need
the Mexicans because of their bending
and crouching habits which the whites
cannot attain themselves to to pick our
agricultural products when historians
come to write about this age in grand
terms like sensibility they'll write
about anxiety and fear as the
overwhelming collective emotions around
the world
you